en principio hablemos de los retos para
la mandataria a nivel interno en medio
de la división política que enfrenta el
parlamento
bueno buenas noches buenos de verdad que
es un
gran privilegio para honduras la primer
mujer que asume la presidencia y eso es
un asunto muy importante no solamente
para honduras sino para toda
centroamérica
hoy la presidenta ha hecho un discurso
muy
esperanzador para la población ha
levantado mucha ilusión en el pueblo
pueblo hondureño que ha venido en una
crisis muy difícil en otros momentos
desde 2017
2009 con huracanes esta idiota con
cantidad de compatriotas migrantes que
van saliendo del país
diariamente entre 800 y 1000 personas
que están saliendo fuera buscando
mejores condiciones de vida entonces la
presidenta tiene enormes retos sin duda
con una deuda que va
quedando hoy de más de 18 mil millones
de dólares eso es más del 70% del
producto interno bruto el rubro más
grande del presupuesto general de la
república y el reto fuerte es cómo
negociar a nivel interno por los
tenedores de la deuda interna igualmente
con la deuda externa que le permita
algún recurso para poder ejercer y hacer
algunas promesas que ha hecho justamente
en su en su campaña
bueno y ahora hablemos de los retos a
nivel internacional por ejemplo que el
mensaje envía la presencia de la de la
vicepresidenta estadounidense kamala
harris en la posesión
sí sin duda que es un gran un gran
espaldarazo vivíamos aquí popularmente
al mandato de la presidenta
xiomara castro y sin duda que el tener
ahora una una embajadora que ha sido
designada para honduras todos estos
otros años anteriores no hemos contado
una una representación diplomática a ese
nivel
eso dice mucho de del apoyo que eeuu
va a brindar a este mandato de la
presidenta xiomara castró y por ahí
también la presencia de otros
mandatarios la el respaldo que ha
planteado el fondo monetario
internacional el respaldo que han
planteado algunos organismos también
otros organismos multilaterales para el
saneamiento de
presidente xiomara castro su gestión